The concept of beauty
and who is considered beautiful
has been a core part of the
human experience for millennia.
And it has long affected
a wide range of social outcomes,
from partner choices,
to hiring decisions,
to life satisfaction.
So it’s no wonder we humans
have a long history
of trying to optimise
our beauty.
And arguably,
that’s intensifying in modern life.
We are living today in the most
prolific visual culture in history.
The obsession with beauty also stems
from new pressures and new freedoms
people are experiencing
in global capitalism today.
Many people have more partner choice
than they did before
as urbanisation grows
and more people date online.
This means that people
may be competing with others
more than before.
More people are also
working in services
where appearance
can be a job requirement
and that can contribute
to body anxiety.
Given the intense social pressure
to look a certain way,
there’s no surprise that
the beauty business is booming -
the industry is currently valued
at around $532 billion.
In 2019,
globally there were over 11 million
cosmetic surgical procedures
and over 13 million non-surgical
procedures, such as Botox.
Of course, there is no one way
of being beautiful,
but every year brings an abundance
of treatments and products
that promise new ways
to try and achieve it.
Like the notorious vampire facial
of the 2010s,
also known as the platelet-rich
plasma facial.
First, a sample of your own blood
is taken and then the plasma -
the liquid part of your blood
that carries cells and proteins -
is extracted then injected
back into your face.
Or, in more recent times,
a range of skin products
containing snail excretions.
Though neither of these
treatments have proven results.
But before you go running
into the garden
to interfere with some molluscs,
you might want to ask yourself
if any of these treatments
and products actually
make you more beautiful.
Is it even possible to get
an objective assessment
as to how beautiful - or not -
you actually are?
Qoves Studio is an Australian based
company who claim to offer just that.
Using machine learning,
Qoves takes in-depth measurements
of your facial features,
and then shows you how you compare
to others within your own ethnicity.
A useful service
or downright terrifying?
At Qoves we have a comprehensive
report where we measure
your facial features
against scientific standards
and then evaluate how far off you are
from the "perfect face".
Now, there is no perfect face,
but generally these standards
of scientific measurement
are the ones that
plastic surgeons would use,
and so it provides a background
briefing before you go in for surgery
if that's what you're interested in.
But is this pursuit
of perfection healthy?
Shouldn’t we love the skin
we’re in?
We're providing you with the research
in a nicely packaged way,
but we always encourage you
to critically think
about your own surgery
and to think about
how beauty actually affects you.
Is it important? Is it important
enough to warrant surgery?
If cosmetic surgery or applying
snail mucus doesn’t appeal to you,
there are thankfully
some less extreme ways
of optimising your beauty.
If you have too much sun exposure,
UV exposure,
this can cause damage to your skin
and the cells in the skin.
The DNA may undergo mutations,
which may eventually
lead to skin cancer.
Because the UV rays can penetrate
deeper into the skin,
they also damage the collagen
and the elastic fibres
that are in the lower layer
of the skin.
And this is what causes
the deep wrinkles.
So when you're out in the sun
for a long time then you should wear
a broad spectrum suncream
or clothes that cover your skin
to prevent that skin damage.
Lack of sleep can release the stress
hormones which are bad for our skin,
also, the skin has its own
internal clock
and so skin cells are programmed
to grow and repair
at night while we sleep.
A good night's sleep
can be subjective,
but on average it’s anywhere
between six and nine hours.
Genetic epidemiologist Tim Spector
says the role of diet
in conditions such as acne
is still unclear.
But he believes that keeping
the microbes in your gut
in good working order,
through reducing processed food
and eating a wide range
of fruit and vegetables,
should help your skin’s
health generally.
So in the future,
we will be able to tell you
which foods you should be eating
to enhance this particular type
of microbe that could help
your skin health.
At the moment,
we're just giving general advice
to increase the helpful microbes in
your gut and reduce the harmful ones.
You might think all this beautifying
is deeply superficial -
but perhaps this pursuit of beauty
is part of what makes
our species unique.
The Kadiwéu people in Brazil
elaborately paint their faces,
the Nuba in the Sudan practice
scarification,
the tattoo, a Polynesian word,
is widespread across the Pacific.
Beauty can have an irresistible pull
for humans,
but we are fundamentally different
from other animals
in that we do not accept
our bodies as they are.